Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
Welcome to Shotgun Farmers
Now imagine yourself an ol' country bumpkin
*country accent* out in the fields lookin after your crops.
When all the sudden other farmers
wanna come in and steal what once was yours
so the only weapon ya gotta hand is the very crops you were trying to tend to
imma drop this stupid accent and im gonna play this
with some-these people..?
Quick play?
I dunno what we're playing but I hope it's gonna be good
so this is a game, it's a multiplayer shooter, where the only thing you can do--
Is shoot with your very crops
BOINK
Sorry, I missed
I fired, then I missed
and apparently, that's melee
BLAM
BLOOM
BLIP
BLAP
Ok, you know what I'm gonna go back to the lobby here
Let's find something here
Fight me, Imma fight this guy
Imma fight this guy
Because I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING
*reads* Plants grow faster near water
Hello
Eliminate the golden hill farmer ranger things..
Hi, you have something in your head
Uhh
How do I-
Hello!
Ah, delightful cows
ooh
AHAHA
OHOH NOO
Exploding Pigeon, you fuck!
Come at me, bruh
You want a piece of me bruh?
mm?!
oooh, you gonna get it
you gonna get it!
you gon get it, you gon get it, you gon get-
oh shit, hi
Hi buddy
Who's gonna get got?
Who wants to get got?
Aanybody wanna piece of my corn?
OAHH
I thought I had you!
Dammit!
Ohh, everyone else is getting kills but me!
This is buncha bullshit!
Good thing we've got an afk over there, that's really useful, I'm super happy about that
hey, harvest..?
WAAAAHAHA
OH come on!
Why is everyone else able to kill me and I'm not able to kill them
A buncha bullshit!
You want sum of this? Huh?
Right outside my door?
Yeah, get killed
get killed!
get killed bruh!
HUP
YUP
HOopdee
oOH  pea-pistol!
Do doo, dooludulu doo
doo duuu
rootin tootin pootin
Ah
I'm pepperin ya!
From a way long way down
ooh boy I'm out of ammo
Lemme just grab some of this!
So I can shoot these a-holes
in the butt
Ah!
HuYEP
Woop
HOOO, get rekt
uh oh, EEEEEHEHHHEE
HEHAHHAA
*demonic voice* I am the avatar of death here
I dunno if I can reload though
Nope! yep I'm out
Imma wack you with a shovel until you can't be wacked no more!
GET WACKED!
ohh... I didn't wack hard enough
I didn't wack HARD ENOUGH
alright, where you guys at?
oop, I see you
WHAT?
I SHOT HIM AND HE SHOT ME AND THEN HE DIE, I DIED?
*really high pitched* I died?
what da hell?
Woah, okay that doesn't make any sense about the lethality of these slugs
cause they are reeeaaaaal powerful apparently
Hey hey, hey why didn't I get an assist on that?
oh, caught some of you, but not enough of you
See why is that-
That seems like extreme lethality, and yet-
OHHHH GET REKT
Revenge wreckage!
Doesn't matter if they kill me, only matters if I kill them right?
That's what matters
They can eat my, shove my CORN
SHOVE MY CORN
uh oh
Woah, that guy went on a spree!
That guy is way better than I am apparently
That's okay
I've got over-confidence on my side
I don't think they do
uh oh, uhhh
I need, something else
Please, something more substantial please
Heh, oh, 'scuse my pathetic performance
Hehe, ohoh
ahaha, ohohoho
gimme that, okay
uh oh
you wanna GO BRUH? YOU WANNA GO?
YOU WANNA GOo? Oh god!
Don't go! Don't go!
HAHA!
Revenge beatdown!
That's a winning for mee!
apparently...
hup, rootin tootin pootin trying to tell me what to do
I know what I'm doing
WHAT?
WHAAT
WHAT
WHAT THE FUCKIN BULLSHIT IS THAT
WHAT A BUNCHA BULLSHIT
Ah! Gotchu
Aha! Gotchu!
Ok that's not good
But I'm gonna grab one of these bad boys here
Ooh almost dead, ooh
Cow! Gimme some sustenance
What is this?
Oh
Ahaha! Noo!
I just got a sniperagus!
I just got a snipergus!
snipergus
Haha! Got you
Aw, that snupergus ain't gonna be there no more, ain't it-
ooh, it is!
one shot though
That's all I neeed
This snupergus ain't gonna be-
not...il-
UTILIZED!
Ohh frick
My snupergus didn't work
Not the way I intended my snupergus to work
Ha! Watcha got there?
A carrot?
AHHA!
Jesus, that wasn't just a carrot. That was a carrot launcher. That is seem's-
HEYYY!
We did it!
WOOOOOO!
Alright! Take some of that
I didn't do to good, but that's alright
I got a new hat
And that's all that matters
That's what I wanted, anyway
That was really cool
Anyway, I've actually never played this game before
I saw it and I just liked the concept of it
Is there a way to practice against bots or anything?
Or is it just practice here?
Oh. Shit. Okay.
That's bots
Okay. Eliminate the red farmers
I didn't know we'd be going right into this
Can I get a snipergus?
Oh this is completely different
Oooh rustic!
Okay, I just wanted to play a round against a full group
Oh this seems almost too comically easy
Oh, euh
euh
Ow, you missed me
*laughs* Seems a lot easier than playing against real players
But that's okay, I'll take the easy-
killins!
Ohohohho!
Oops
Uh, stopped laughing
Hooo!
You want some of this?
Wonkage?
Wumpage?
I am almost dead
Hohohoho, I'm milking it
Missed me
uh oh
my me oiym moin murg
Okay.
Udderly ridiculous
I know, right?
Eh!
Ehuhuh!
I am on a roll against-
ookay...
against bots, is what I was gonna say
against silly stupid little bots
but you know, you take what you can get
I wanna find another carrot launcher- I haha
I wanna see how that works against the unending hoards
But I guess I'll take a snipergus
OOP!
SHUP, ShuBOOPADOOP
You guys want some?
Boink
Huh, weird, huh?
AHAHAHOW!
AHAHOW!
The bots got better!
Or I got worse!
I dunno which one is which!
But I gotta find the carrot bomb...
More snippergus
Oh, imma get a vantage point here
what do you think you're doing?
Boink!
What the hell!
There we go
Oh what are you doing standing out in the open like THAT!
Oh noo
Wait I thought I could kill you- well,
I can't kill nobody 'parently
Er oh ok, you're dead now
Well
I guess that's it for that then
Can someone please lead me to a god damn carrot bomb?
carrot bomb..
Hello
Oh yes please
ooh NELLIE
That went awry
Ohh!
Only one?
Oh what a buncha bull, Thought that was gonna be-
Ooh I run way faster with the shovel
Thaats why everyone was doing the shovel
uhhh, this makes a lot more sense...
ohhh that is waaay faster
gooshki
that was 'spose to-
gooshki!
stop movin!
ya frickin douches
ohh, lemme gooshki ya
gooshki!
ohh! I'm such a bad gooshker
fine I'll do these until I can get another frickin carrot boomb...
oh, tiny carrot
you're gonna be great some day
I'll take you now though
Alright, get ready for a whole face full of this shit!
SHUP!
OOHOOHOOHOO
HOOHOOHOO
Ah, what's going on here?
What you guys got going on?
What's going on
Hey, stop this.
Hey, stop
What is this
AHAHOW!
Cucumber?
Cucumber??
I wanna cucumber!
Ooh there's a carrot
That's the thing, like, if I shoot, and miss with the carrot, that means someone else is gonna get it, riight?
That's how it works, I think, anyway
SHOOP
Heeheheh
Come here you!
Donk! *strange chuckle*
YuuuuOPIE
YOPIE
uh oh
Uh, ehh, oh missed.
I am the-
AHAH, I am not as good as I was hoping I would be
I'm losing it for our team here, i'm really really
suckin it up here
Alright sniperagus
time to get sniped
woop
nope
yup, there we go
going to the top of the tower
dukudollulullu, boink!
ello, I can see the whole world from up here
Boink!
You can see the whole world from down dere
Now that your eyes are on the other side of your face
Boink!
Aw c'mon!
HYUAAA
op, no one's alive apparently...
alright then i'll go get a
frickin carrot berrrrmb
Is this a fully harvested carrot bermb?
No, not quite
Ooh, does anyone want to get carroted?
Can I rocket jump the fuck out of somebody?
Please tell me I can
Please, please tell me it is so!
Hey, why don't you group together?
Like that!
That'd be great
Thank you for that!
Oh, that really made me feel good!
oh shit
this is gonna make me feel even better
doooshki!
dooski!
duu double kill!
duuu triple kill!
nuu it can't be so, it is
tooo violent for me
how could anybody survive?
oh look a dinky carrot going to turn into big 'splosion
Get ready for a big boom
I missed it went right through you assholes
Oops, I killed many
didn't mean to, suddenly happen
Get in face
Oh no, you get wumpage
oh no, excuse
excuse me
ex-scuuuse me
uhh bescuse
oiiehh soorry
I'm so soorry about this one
watch, and learn
carrot
oh no!
uh deeaaath?
Thank you! There's lots of carrots 'round here
AWUMP
sorry
just on a rampage, can't help it
too good for buns (?)
too good for buuns (??)
*normal voice* So what is-
Oh, it's the pea gun
Oh okay, well that's nice
That's actually kinda nice
Boink, boink, boink
If I can hit anybody
HO!
Ah, do the wump, ah fack
*goofy voice* I got wumped back in return
*normal* boy, I sure got confident when I started playing against stupid bots
AY! I won against stupid bots!
I feel validated in my life!
That was pretty fun, that was really fun
I gotta admit, this game is really fun
That's the thing about it right?
If it's fun, it's good
Ooh can I custom- *gaaaaasp*
oh a trucker cap! yeaaah
yeeaaah, oh can I get pink hair? I'm gonna yeahh
Can I get a Ponytail? yeahhh
Can I get a musta-
Oh fuck yeah! Make me bald! Fuck!
ooooh I like it!
Gimme that face. Skin color
duh duh duh daaah
Eye color. Where's turd brown?
uh, nose color. Pht..
Whaa...?
Fuckin got the tumblr nose goin on here
Super red for some reason
Voice?
*deep raspy voice* heuh heuh that's me
Aww man, more people need to play this, it's so fun! (hint, hint)
Aw, why don't more people play this, it's so fun?!
Ah it's cool. I hope you guys play it more
I'm actually all out of time for this episode here
but this is a really fun game!
I mean it costs like, I think it's like 10 bucks
I have nothing to do with the game, so I have no stake in it
but it's really fun!
I gotta admit, it's really fun
And like the bots are dumb and whatever
but like it's charming, it's well made, I like it
the concept is good
I wish there was more dynamic between shooting and getting guns
but still, that's really cool! So...
Anyway, that's all the time I've got
So thank you everybody so much for watching
Lemme know what you think down in the comments below
And if you're playing it for yourself, you might just see me on the server
so thanks again
And as always, I will see you,
in the next video
BUHBYE!
*Outro music*